cancer drugs are notoriously expensive
but they've been pretty much immune to
price pressure even as the cost of other
prescription drugs has become a hot
button issue in American politics
thousands of dollars for a single pill
but that can't last new cancer medicines
that harness the immune system can make
diseases that once death sentences
potentially survivable but just one of
these so-called immune oncology drugs
cost a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars per patient per year in the u.s.
these trucks can be even more effective
when you use two at once but the first
approved pair from bristol-myers Squibb
cost a whopping two hundred fifty six
thousand dollars a year many more such
drug combinations are coming and we have
no idea what they're gonna cost five
leading companies are testing their
immune boosting drugs more than 68,000
patients these expensive clinical
Charles are going to help balloon the
cost of future cancer drugs particularly
in the u.s. in fact one estimate
predicts worldwide cancer drug spending
could go as high as one hundred and
seventy eight billion by 2020 up from
about a hundred and seven billion last
year and the u.s. spends more than any
other country due to a lack of pricing
regulation the price of branded cancer
medicines in the u.s. is about eighty
six hundred dollars a month in the UK
it's only about twenty five hundred
dollars sooner or later that growing
price gap is going to prompt scrutiny
from the government and from the private
sector one piece of good news
there are already three immune oncology
medicines on the market that could be
the backbone of new drug combinations
and soon there may be five old-fashioned
competition and pressure from insurers
she'd help bring prices down
any drug company expecting the pricing
status quo to last forever is in for a
nasty surprise